The Unreal Engine project browser can be used to help you create projects as well as browse
recent projects that you have opened on your local computer.
From this tool, we can create a number of projects based on Epic Provided Templates or select
the Blank template.
Let's go ahead and take a look at how we can use this tool and the editor.
We can access this tool and the editor a number of different ways.
First off, we can go up here to File and we have the new project and the open project.
The open project, what this is going to do is this is going to allow us to open any projects
that we currently have on our computer.
Come up here to File and New Projects.
This is where we're going to get access to the project wizard, which allows us to select
a number of different templates provided by Epic.
One of the things to note here under the project defaults, if you're unaware, a project can
be either based on Blueprint code, which is the default, or C++.
If you do select C++, you will need to have Visual Studio or some other type of compiler
installed so that you can compile the required files.
Underneath that, we have our target platform.
We can change this to desktop or mobile.
You might want to change this if you know you are targeting a mobile or a lower end device
or keep it at desktop if you know that you are targeting a desktop or a console.
Quality preset allows us to set this to maximum.
The defaults are scalable.
Scalable would be set in tandem if you were to set this to mobile, so you want to start
with as few options as possible and then through testing, enable options as you have performance
to do that.
Last but not least, we have the starter content.
The starter content is a collection of content that can be used to help you quickly get up
and started with prototyping inside of the engine.
You do have the ability to also specify your project's location and the name of the project.
Once you have everything set, you simply hit Create and your new project will be created
and loaded right inside of the editor.